[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Norris I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John we answer your
questions give you devious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how you
do it I'll tell you what Hank I'm doing
great and I'll tell you why it's because
I have discovered a website that allows
me to gamble on the outcome of the
United States elections called predicted
org are you familiar with this website
uh no I am NOT because of how I don't
want to think any more about elections
and I hate gambling well I mean this
brings together two of your favorite
things then there's an amazing podcast
called election profit-making hosted by
David Rees who you might remember as the
person who made you an artisanal 'i
sharpened pencil one Christmas yes but
also created a wonderful webcomic called
get your war on back in 2001 a
fascinating strange beautifully
eccentric man and this this podcast
called election profit-making I believe
it's called is devoted entirely to
trying to make money on these predictive
election markets and I have joined one
and right now Hank I'm up 98 cents do
you want to know how I've made my 98
cents mostly no one's been elected yet
what did you vote on mostly I voted that
in the final debate the word rigged
would be said by the debate moderator
but then when it went way up I sold it
so the debate hasn't even happened yet
as we're recording this but I already
made 98 cents off of it boy I hate this
I this say this makes me sits like you
take the thing that's making me most
nervous in the world and you combine it
with the other thing that makes me most
nervous in the world man it is a dark
dark time in American history but I am
making money like you wouldn't believe
98 cents here 98 cents they're making
money making money I'm about to actually
buy man will a woman be the next United
States president gonna buy 10 shares of
that right now while we're potting
I really feel like we need to make it
clear that this is a bad idea and that
no one should go to this website and
they are not sponsoring us and we hate
this mmm
I wouldn't say that I hate it so much as
I've been brought to such a dark and
empty place by the election season that
this is the only thing that makes me
feel now how are you doing
I don't know I I just googled this and
and there's that there's a Cora asked is
there a way to make money off of the
election of Trump and 2016 like I'm so
sure that Trump is gonna get elected
that that I should be betting on it
however I can and everybody's gonna
believe that it's not going to happen
but I am and so I need to get to this
election market real fast and I'm taking
that guy's money as we speak did you ask
me a question I asked how you're doing
oh I'm okay it's it's uh as we will hear
in the Mars news section of the podcast
it is a mixed day for a Hank green but
but I don't want to talk about that yet
I did get a haircut though and it looks
fantastic and I just want to shout out
to Brooke for giving me that that super
super-great
you know you know head shape it's just
great I'm really impressed with it well
I'm thrilled that you got a great
haircut America's in the toilet all
right you got a question for us John I
just I got a quick update the markets
have changed slightly in the last 45
seconds I just made another 32 cents I'm
up a dollar 30 Oh God
well I'm so glad that you could find new
way new what exciting ways to meet to
make a living John Hague this question
comes from tandra who asks dear john and
hank i really enjoyed bubble baths and i
was discussing with a friend if having
bubble baths was a hobby or an interest
i believe a hobby is something you do
that you can get better at and an
interest is something you simply enjoy
is there a skill to bubble baths can it
be my hobby or must I resigned it to
simply being an interest can you imagine
if you're like filling out an online
dating profile and it asked for your
hobbies and you said bubble baths I mean
I would read
with that person not because I even
enjoy bubble baths but just because I
like the idea of that like you know what
I like my hobby is leisure right is just
chilling out and letting my muscles not
do anything I recently had to fill out a
questionnaire for for a therapy thing
and one of the questions was if I had
any hobbies and the more I thought about
it I actually appreciate Tundras
definition of hobby the more I thought
like I don't know what a hobby is yeah
because you don't necessarily have to be
getting better at maybe maybe that that
is kind of an interesting approach to it
and I haven't thought about this enough
to like find all the potential
exceptions but I like it I like it as a
definition and secondarily I would say
that you can absolutely get better at
bubble baths doing a good bubble bath is
not something you're born knowing how to
do yeah and I think that you could
introduce you could introduce new
elements to your bubble baths there are
all of these yep bath salts you could be
creating your own bath bomb type things
Catherine has a whole shelf full of
stuff that she puts in baths and
sometimes she will have me put out meal
into the food processor so that it will
get into smaller pieces of oatmeal
because that is good apparently for me
Hank it's a little bit like how lots of
people drink wine but only some people
have wine as a hobby you know what I
like
hobby wine people know a lot about right
right
and you can get I'm sure that certainly
people who like make these bath products
like they probably started as just
lovers of bathing and then wanted to
continue making that making that a
bigger part of their lives which I
totally you know your head had done a
very dangerous road here this is a very
dangerous road because the last thing
you want to do is turn your hobby into a
job that's like the number one mistake
that Hank makes in every facet of his
life is turning his hobbies into his job
yeah it is it is something that I that I
do make a mistake of I want to tell you
something that I was fascinated by the
when I recently bought oatmeal for
Catherine's bath John there are a number
of ways to buy oatmeal but if you're
just getting it for bathing you just get
the Quaker Oats and they come in this
big cylindrical cardboard thing and
there's like 45 servings in it and it
costs
like four dollars I don't know why
anyone eats anything else like the the
the whole all of the world's problems
are solved if only this stuff tasted
good yeah I mean I guess that's probably
why people don't eat only oatmeal all
the time is because oatmeal is delicious
on occasion but it's not like a
breakfast lunch and dinner kind of food
it's not like pizza
yeah it's gruel literally like that's
that's what it I don't know if it's
literally gruel I don't know what gruel
is let me google it I don't think I've
ever been so interested in something in
my entire life can we move on to another
question
anyway job this question is from Sarah
it's what edits for me so I'm gonna read
it it says dear Hank and John often in
sci-fi television shows and films by
opening an airlock
the enemy is sucked into space and dies
but the protagonists who are opening the
airlock are buckled in so they aren't
sucked out but I'm confused
how do they live I have the impression
ever since I first learned about space
as a kid that as soon as a spacesuit or
a spacecraft is breached anyone
occupying that space is almost
immediately dead do you have any
thoughts on this John
mmm no you can how long would you say
that you can live in the vacuum of space
I would say like four minutes yeah it's
quite a long time you would think not a
long time that would be and also I bet
it's not a fun four minutes well it's
the vast majority of that four minutes
you have no idea exist you are
unconscious at 15 seconds and this
actually has happened not in space but
thank goodness but it has happened with
people on earth being exposed to near
vacuum spaces and and the one time that
had happened in NASA training he was
unconscious in 14 seconds but he
survived and the main trick is to make
sure that you blow all of the air out of
your lungs because if you're if your
lungs stay stay like closed off the
oxygen inside will expand and rupture
your lungs forcing oxygen into your
blood which will kill you for sure
Wow that sounds terrible but if you are
out in the vacuum of space and a bunch
of nasty terrible things will happen to
you but you can if you'll fall
unconscious but if somebody brings you
back in
in before your brain goes dead from lack
of oxygen you you could totally survive
it's wonderful news you know people say
that this podcast contains no useful
information but I'll tell you what the
rest of my life when I am in a near
vacuum situation I'm gonna get that air
out of my lungs that's right
you don't know what's gonna happen John
you could become a total thrill-seeking
adventurist in the future and find
yourself on the surface of Mars by the
time you're 85 you don't know what kind
of person you're gonna become you never
know III don't know that I agree with
that I think by my age it's mostly set
in stone but I do have a question on the
subject of anxiety Hank it comes from
Paul he writes dear John and Hank my
wife and I are about to go on a vacation
for several days leaving our two small
children alone with their grandmother
for the first time in the days
immediately preceding the trip my
excitement for the time with my wife has
switched to a very specific dread I am
afraid that something will happen to my
wife and I while we are away and thus we
will abandon our children my anxiety
about this scenario has grown almost to
the point I don't want to go anymore
what can I do to overcome this and this
type of specific dread in my life first
thing I would say Paul is obviously it's
very unlikely that you and your wife are
going to die and if it did happen it
would be a horrible tragedy
on the other hand Harry Potter never
would have happened if he wasn't an
orphan yes so if if you get murdered by
a dark wizard on your vacation exact
everything will turn out okay it'll be
good for the world as a whole right yeah
it'll be bad in the short run but I
would argue that like in terms of like
the quality of entertainment that will
be produced as a result of it it's
almost goodness I am I'm dreading my
future dread as my birth of my child
approaches and I have no idea how I'm
going to feel or what I'm gonna do but I
I don't know what kind of person I'm
gonna be in a month and that is worrying
to me is it does that make sense yeah no
I definitely think it changes things a
little bit but I also think that you
know you you you bring your personality
to parenting you know you it's not like
you
are suddenly inhabiting a different
consciousness so I wouldn't worry that
much I mean except insofar as you know
your insufficiencies and shortcomings
will no doubt be highlighted as has been
the case for me I think as a parent no
but what I would say to Paul seriously
is you know that's a very low
probability outcome and it also
constantly exists though going on
vacation does not make it significantly
more likely that both you and your wife
will die it may you know and so what
what's really going on I suspect is that
you have this deep down fear that like
is extremely intense because it would be
a you know a terrible terrible thing and
in those situations I try to do two
things one I try to remind myself that
this is not a likely outcome and so that
I'm not really thinking rationally about
it and two I try to remember that I'm
setting an example for my children and
if I go through life afraid all the time
they will notice that and I think it
will make things probably more difficult
for them rather than easier so I just
try to remind myself of that and I try
really hard to act as rationally as I
can but it's really really hard it's
hard to be a dad and you know those
those fears are real so I'm sorry but I
also think you should have a great time
on vacation and try try not to worry
about it and just enjoy it
alright that's good John good job I'm
gladly take on some serious questions
and some science questions and some
silly questions that's what I feel like
that's bearded you're Hank Adamo is what
what do you got for me John while we're
on the topic of serious questions I'm
just wondering if we can address a
question we've gotten numerous time but
without reading a specific question
because I don't want to make anybody's
life harder yeah actually I think I had
this exact same thought and we didn't
even discuss it beforehand but go and
we'll see if I have the same thought if
you are a man or really if you're anyone
but especially if you're a man are
we having the same thought I think we
are and a woman tells you or anyone
tells you that they are not interested
in having a romantic relationship with
you if they tell you that even once you
must listen to that and you must listen
to it forever period it's a pretty much
a pretty much becomes a permanent state
of affairs that usually that isn't taken
lightly by the person being like hey
this is the first thing that comes out
of my mouth is that I'm not interested
in that that that that is a considered
position and and continuing to push it
is it can be very uncomfortable and even
frightening and can make relationships
much more difficult and we've gotten we
we've gotten a form of that question so
many times yeah and and feel strange
about answering the specific question
because it like often has enough details
that you could sort of pick out the
situation but but yes if you think that
you have ever made a woman uncomfortable
because you have continued suggesting
that you could be in a relationship and
and she has not been receptive to that
and you're wondering if that has had a
negative impact on your relationship
with that person had negative impact on
that person themselves that's probably
the case yeah and and I and I've done
note I totally did that as a younger
person and I what and I just I wanted it
I wanted to make it work and I wanted to
see how I could do it and and my brain
just kept being like well maybe maybe
things have changed maybe now maybe it's
different but but there's a lot of fish
in the sea
well if thoughts just that I don't think
it's uh think it's merely like
uncomfortable I think ultimately it's a
kind of four form of abuse or harassment
to go back to someone again and again
and again and say has anything changed
can we be on relationship now if someone
has told you that they don't want to be
in a relationship you have to honor that
and if you are having trouble honoring
that that means that you are having a
problem that you need to seek out health
four and you need to make sure that you
do not push that relationship on that
person because I think it can become
very scary and kind of dangerous so I
just felt like we should say that good
it's interesting that I had that exact
same thought when reading that question
because I have seen it so many times and
yeah we've just seen different versions
of that question so many times and it is
I mean this is a constant it it's a
problem for lots of different people but
I think especially for women and and
it's something that we need to
acknowledge goes on in our culture and
as men I think we need to do something
about yeah I had it happened once to me
where somebody was continued to hit on
me for a long long time
and after I had made it clear that I
wasn't interested in that and that I was
in a relationship at the time and it was
amazing how fast it felt like harassment
I and I were yeah cuz it is yeah I had I
had never I would never have thought
like like he thinks he's just being
silly and fun but really he wants
something from me and I keep saying no
he keeps saying but but this is silly
fun time and I'm just I'm just you know
trying to get you to do a thing that you
don't want to do or the drunken
confession or whatever there's many
forms of it but it's always bad and
indicative of of a real problem I think
so yeah okay I'm glad we're on the same
page about that Hank we are our advice
often disagrees with each other but not
on that topic however I do have a topic
on which our advice is almost certain to
disagree who is it is it which which is
the best flavor of Lucroy is that one of
the questions no no I just I thought I
just thought that we might disagree on
that I didn't see that I didn't see that
question but I certainly think that we
will agree on the best favor of Lucroy
because there is only one best flavor of
Lucroy I mean you could make a case for
three or four but I think there's one
overwhelming favorite let's just both
say our favorites at the same time on
three one two three pomplamoose oh no
and I said Pomplamoose which is my
favorite flavor of Lacroix and it is the
best flavor of Lacroix and
I don't even think I've ever had orange
it's delicious it's delicious and the
best part about it is nobody else in my
family likes it so they don't steal mine
well that's a definite definite sign
that it's the objectively best is that
no one else in your house likes it yep I
know Hank I've got a question for you
this question comes from Sharon who asks
Dear John and Hank recently you answered
a question about how to feel confident
in yourself and your product / work when
surrounded by people much older than you
I was wondering if you have any advice I
love her dubious it may be don't worry
Sharon it will be very dubious about how
one can deal with the feeling of being
crowded out by younger people especially
in newer technology related fields
imagining others complexly means that I
can understand the fear of starting
something new as a young person but in
today's world I often feel like people
on either side of that age spectrum are
gunning for you
they are Sharon and you have to take
them out it's the only way yes that's
your advice yeah don't you agree Hank
like when it comes if you're an old
person and you've got young people in a
technology related field gunning for
your job with their knowledge of the
snapchat and the tinder and however else
young people are getting their marketing
these days you've just got to take that
person out like like like hire a hit
person no not literally I mean you just
undermine them at work constantly Oh
like someone will say like who did this
terrible thing at the office and you'll
be like I bet it was trying to think of
a good young person named Caden Trent
Trent it was Trent and Caden they were
they're the worst they're so bad at
snapchat on the one who knows how to
snapchat I feel like no one's been named
Trent in ever it's like yeah well you're
the one who came up with Trent I had
Kate it's the perfect millennial name
and then you delivered Trent which is
very low quality apologize yeah all the
train killed the bit other than that the
bit with so much and I feel bad it was a
solid bit oh man I've all the trends out
there gonna be super unhappy right now
if you're if you're Trent you can email
us at Hank and John at gmail.com and let
us know how many trench there are
listening right now
she lied to us I was gonna say we're
gonna get 99 faked rents and then maybe
maybe one real Trent but even that real
Trent it'll probably be like Trent's
middle name you know yeah I actually I
wanted to I wasn't gonna answer this
question because I have no good answer
for this it's interesting because I
think a lot of young people are feeling
like oh they're like these like people
are staying in their jobs longer and
longer they're putting off retirement so
they're not making any space for me in
the job market the way that space was
made for them in the job market and then
at the same time a lot of older people
are like oh my god these younger people
are have a lot of skills that I don't
have and they're cheap for people to
hire and there are lots of them coming
into the workforce right now and there
must there must be you know I think that
I think that what might might be
happening John is that it's complicated
ya know I think all you can do is
understand that yes there are things
that young people are better at at your
job that's true it on my office by the
way as well like the young people here
are much better at large swathes of the
internet than I am and that is
intimidating in a way but you have a
different set of skills you have like
there is a set of skills that comes with
having been in the workplace for a long
time from you know understanding having
the institutional knowledge of the
company that you work for or the
industry that you work in and that's
valuable as well so I think mainly it's
just focusing on the value that you have
to give rather than focusing on the
things that you aren't good at and then
the other thing I would say is like it's
not like you can't download snapchat
yeah yeah I mean depending on what
depending on what this is I think that
you definitely have to consider your
best to consider continuing to develop
your skills at the same time young
people have more time to do that and if
you have a yeah as as usual I think that
Hank is a great source of wisdom on this
and every topic I think do we have
another question and do not do not have
your fellow employees murdered by hit
people good I'm glad that you got that
in that's important advice and yes I do
have another question is from Kate who
asks do
Hank and John I'm a teacher and have
taught at the same school for sixteen
years I'm a department chair and a
building leader it's in quotation marks
so I assume it's some kind of official
title my partner recently got a job at a
different area and we will be moving at
the end of the term would it be
appropriate for me to just ghost out of
my job I don't want to tell people I'm
leaving because they will all want to
talk about it non-stop I'm a fairly
private person and I hate being the
center of attention any dubious advice
is appreciated this question made me a
gate and I don't know exactly what you
mean by ghosting under your job but if
you are in a position of leadership at
your school you at the very least need
to tell your supervisor that you're
leaving before you leave do you I mean
well maybe if it's like at the end of
the semester and you're just like well
the semester ended I won't be coming
back after the summer break oh right
that was my assumption that Kate was
gonna make it to the end of the school
year and then just very quietly on the
first day of summer tell Kate supervisor
I will no longer be working yeah I got
all year not that Kate would just not
okay everything's okay everything's
alright if Kate if that is your plan
then you could do that if you're gonna
give people two months to find a
replacement for you please please do
whatever you would like I just don't
want you to not show up on deck which is
how I read ghosting I love the idea of
just not showing up on a Wednesday and
then somebody somebody calls your cell
phone and you're like hey and they're
like hey you teach us government and
you're not here and you're just like
yeah well no I move I'm an Oregon I'm
gonna Oregon right now in my new house
with all my stuff so the kids are here
can't come in how did you get this how
did you get this number I changed my
mind numbered in my new Oregon over so
weird that you were able to track me
down anyway I don't work for you anymore
I don't ever need a reference ever again
yeah there's a happy medium I think
between I understand that urge not to
want to have this like lengthy farewell
with parties and conversations and cakes
and whatnot but at the same time you do
need to make sure that the
school has the resources that they need
to replace you because it sounds like
you are a really significant part of it
the only other thing I would say is that
while it is uncomfortable to do the
cakes and everything it's kind of nice
if you can bear it to allow people to
say goodbye and to say the reasons that
they are grateful to have worked for you
even if that's not fun for you it can be
very rewarding for other people I think
so
if you can stomach it I do think that
there's some there's some reason to gut
it out but I totally empathize with not
wanting to that's really great advice
John and I think really thoughtful and I
think that we can have another question
now if you got one this question comes
from Walker and he asks Dear John and
Hank why is there a single word for
hungry and thirsty but not one for
needing to use the restroom Walker I
have no idea what you're talking about
uh you don't you don't call that feeling
poopie and a bladder full there's two
words there's poopie and bladder full
and those words existed I don't know
what's wrong with you
I'm poopy oh man excuse me I have to go
I'm flattered for a bladder full is an
incredibly important word that has never
existed before just this moment I bet
it's on urban dictionary I don't think
so I'm gonna Google bladder full right
now oh I did too I don't have that
nothing came right now not only is
bladder fell'd not a word or should I
say wasn't a word until 20 seconds ago
when it became a word for the rest of
human history oh wait there is bladder
filiz on urban dictionary I regret to
inform you it has an incredibly long
long definition I can't read it to you
because it's the the length of a novel
um Oh bladder full according to urban
dictionary is where you pee yourself I
don't like that I think that that's
terrible definition and I think that we
need to change I totally agree I totally
agree bladder full yeah no we have
established okay the second definition
of bladder foe is the feeling of needing
to pee established by Jay Bennett back
in
February actually on Valentine's Day
2009 way to spend your Valentine's Day
doing something productive J Bennett
Blatter 'fl the feeling of needing to
pee so Hank did not invent Blatter Phil
it was invented so far as we can tell by
urban dictionary user J Bennett on
Valentine's Day so romantic 2009 bladder
full is it's a revelation for me Hank I
think we need everybody to go to urban
dictionary and search for bladder fall
with one L at the end not to elves and
everybody can thumb up J Bennett's
answer so that it can be the top listing
instead of this novel about peeing in
your pants because it is obviously the
correct definition of bladder fall Hank
while I was looking on the internet at
bladder fall I also glanced at my
predicted org situation and I just want
to update you that I have lost 25 cents
from earlier man today I know
apparently the chances that the US
Senate race in North Carolina will go to
the Democrats have declined by about a
quarter which is 1% to be clear I have
$25 bet on that that outcome what is
wrong with me that I have devoted so
much of my life and consciousness to
this election cycle Hank uh well I think
that it's something that's wrong with a
lot of people at the same time so it
can't just be you it seems to be a
pretty human thing and it's pretty
remarkable the you know we forget that
in like a normal time there's news all
the time right so there's constant news
right but right now the top story on
every thing is always about the election
everywhere we go
so all that other news is still
happening and no one has any idea that
it even exists it's amazing what other
news are you referring to I don't I
don't really think i actually think that
most of the time it's just that there is
no news well I mean it's things like you
know Netflix had a million more
subscribers this quarter the people who
thought they were and like a u.s.
battleship firing on a radar
installation in Yemen like this is a big
deal and
people know about it but it would be the
top thing and just because every day
it's the election the election the
election is the only from the people are
thinking about like you know we fired on
a nation this here's a very unstable
situation in Yemen right now and and and
also somewhat in Saudi Arabia and it's
like that's freaky and what we can't
think about that we have to think about
the debate
I appreciate your attempts to get me to
think about something other than US
electoral politics however can I ask you
one more question about US electoral
politics yeah okay can we just please
ask our listeners to vote to vote even
if they think their votes won't count to
vote to pay attention not just to the
presidential election but also to down
ballot elections and to please go and
please please please vote yes vote for
us as you know let's not write Hank and
John in I will be furious
don't vote for us do the thing for us if
not for you do it for me if you cannot
think of a good reason to vote please
think of how anxious I am every minute
of every day waiting for this stupid
election to be over and how much I
personally need you personally to vote
alright the other person I would say you
should vote for is rosianna because
rosianna is a British citizen who has
been forced to live in the United States
during this darkest of timelines so she
had to watch brexit from afar and now
she is having to live with an American
election cycle which is one of the worst
things that can happen to a human being
and she cannot even affect the election
outcome because she is not allowed to
vote so please vote for rosianna alright
well we've also got a very important
question that I need to get to from
Rachel though John so this is this okay
she asked dear Hank and John
occasionally I will get a salad from the
salad bar at the grocery store usually I
put chicken or turkey on it but instead
of Turkey now they have these
rubber looking crab chunks that I have
learned are called imitation crab what
even is imitation crab why is it a thing
how much of imitation crabmeat is crab
and how much is quote-unquote crab
bumpkins and penguins and imitation crab
Rachel how much of imitation crab is
crab I've always assumed that it was
clams no imitation crab is 0% crab it is
a mostly fish
it's basically so you know how like when
you get a chicken nugget at a fast-food
restaurant it's not like chicken it's
chicken it's made of chicken but it's
like ground-up chicken that's got a
bunch of other stuff in it to like make
it into a chicken paste that then is
sort of like where is it like like chips
like chicken foam that's basically what
imitation crab is it's it's ground-up
fish with like bind binders in it so
that it can be roughly the texture of
crab and then they put flavor in it to
make it taste a little more like crab
they put color in it to make it look a
little more like crab but it's it's
mostly fish oh God it's fish product and
and I don't know why it exists I I find
it to be unpleasant
I mean if your goal for the day was to
make sure I never eat a California roll
or a chicken nugget for the rest of my
life then congratulations
is there imitation crab in California
rolls yeah that's what a California roll
is man oh I feel sick to my stomach I do
not want to go back in time to the time
before you answered that question first
of all I looked it up a California roll
it has either crab meat or imitation
crab so maybe you don't know maybe
you've been eating just the one kind
second it's all food it's just it's
basically just imagined that someone
cooked a a recipe that was ground fish
meat and some like cornstarch and a
little bit of red food coloring that's
that's the recipe that they prepared for
you at an industrial factory with lots
of stainless steel and factory workers
okay we have to move on to another
question because I'm starting to glimpse
the darkness I'm becoming too aware of
my microbiome as sometimes happens this
question comes from Danielle
who asks Dear John and Hank my boyfriend
and I were discussing the decision to
send the song dark was the night cold
was the ground by Blind Willie Johnson
as the only piece of music on the
Voyager into space it was my first time
hearing it but it was oddly fitting when
thinking of it floating in space
endlessly my question to you too is if
you could only send one song into the
depths of space to hopefully be heard by
aliens
what would you send John what would it
be if it weren't the mountain goats well
that's not a fair question because
mountain goats Danielle I disagree with
your premise are we living in some kind
of alternate history where the mountain
goats never existed and if so what else
is different about American history is
there no Trump and it's okay and if so
can we make this happen
no it wouldn't be worth it Hank the
mountain goats are too important if it
couldn't be the mountain goats if it
couldn't be the mountain goats you know
I don't know if you can I might send one
of the songs from John Coltrane's a love
supreme which is probably my favorite
non mountain goats piece of music I'm
not sure which one no Hank what would
you send well I think that if I was
given the opportunity to send something
into the depths of space on a golden
record pretty hard not to write my own
song and be like this is the song for
the golden record that's gonna go to the
aliens yeah that's just that's so
terrible that's borderline evil yeah I
know oh man okay I'm gonna go with the
last part of a love supreme which is
called Psalm I think that's what I'm
gonna go with but they're all so good
there's no bad part of a love supreme
it's kind of one piece of music so maybe
I get to send the whole thing if I could
set a song by the mountain goats that
would also be extremely difficult
because the mountain goats have several
thousand songs and there
all truly excellent but I guess in the
end I would probably go with up the
wolves
no bad mountain goat songs it's one of
the one of the great gifts of that band
they've even got a great song about a
brand of peanuts
which reminds me John this podcast is
brought to you by a brand of peanuts
that the mountain goats like I guess
yeah its Golden Boy peanuts actually
this podcast was also brought to you by
the vacuum of space the vacuum of space
exhale podcasts additionally was brought
to you by the chances but a woman will
be elected president the chances that a
woman will be elected president so far
responsible for a 30 cents of john's
network no much closer to a dollar whoa
there's been a huge change Hank I just
made 60 cents hey we'll get back to that
in a second and lastly this podcast is
brought to you by the word bladder
--fill the word bladder 'fl covering the
feeling of needing to pee since
Valentine's Day 2009 I think I've got to
see why why was there this huge change
in my net worth something extremely
dramatic has happened people have
discovered the election markets and they
are excited to take the money of Trump
supporters know what happened Hank is
that the chances that one of the
nominees will win at least three hundred
seventy electoral votes in the electoral
college has risen up to 36% I bought at
27% I'm a genius I should have put all
my net worth into this market I wanna
vomit just thinking about this I gotta
get out of the stock market and this
book writing business podcasting
vlogbrothers saying this was all it was
all a preface Hank it was all a preface
for the great chapter of my life known
as the vindictive org chapter okay could
we just say to everybody out there who's
feeling like there is a grain of truth
in what john is saying and that there is
a way to make money gambling that your
brain is messing with you and never ever
do that well I've got a dollar eighty
one that says otherwise Hank but
but to be clear yeah I i gamble with
tens of cents we've got a got a question
that I was able to get to it's a
correction actually from Krista who and
I think this important thing to talk
about because we discussed earlier Alec
Alec una in there there's no word for
needing to potty but this is another one
that I really was fascinated to discover
Krista says dear Hank and John bull
semen comes from bulls and and cows are
female so bull semen cannot come from a
cow no matter how awesome that cow is I
don't know why being awesome would
increase the chance that a female cow
could create semen but I have to so John
what is the word for a cow that is just
a gender-neutral term for a single
animal of that species like you would
say a dog or a cat or a pig what is that
is it
is it well the plural is cattle so I
would guess perhaps it is Catelyn there
isn't a word for this oh well now there
is Catelyn yes cat lab there it is
people sometimes someone will say a head
of cattle so like one cow of
indeterminate gender is a head of cattle
mm-hmm but yeah so I so basically in
English we use the word cow as a
gender-neutral term for a head of cattle
and that thus I have to say Krista
you're wrong and I was right and until
the word cat ylim comes into a you know
regular use in English language then I
can continue to wear the badge of not
being wrong about that one thing well
which is all that's important to peplum
is now in regular English usage and also
I'm very excited about our spin-off
podcast Dear John and Hank the
Linguistics Edition where we do nothing
but invent words for what is it called
glue Cunha are those places where there
are no words for things that exist yes
correct
I love that there's a word for words
that don't exist yeah that's a beautiful
word we also have a correction from
daniel turner who writes dear john and
hank my name is
Daniel don't try to Ryan me Daniel I see
what you're doing and I am an enrolled
agent which means I'm licensed by the
IRS with their highest credential and
then Daniel points out that I was
totally wrong about my statement that
there is no advantage to dying on
January 1st in fact there is a huge
advantage at least if you are married
because if your spouse dies and you are
married filing jointly you can claim an
extra exemption and also you can file
the claim married filing jointly even
though you were only married for one day
of the year this is the kind of Darkness
that our tax policy forces us to think
about I don't want to think about it but
the IRS makes me uh Daniel goes on to
say that January 1st as far as he can
tell is the best day to die and then he
says I hope that I die on January 1st
hopefully not this year though man man
hold on Daniel yeah just hold on Daniel
it's gonna be okay what is that great
line from that old bluegrass song won't
you spare me over for another year
it's a beautiful line where the singer
is asking God for for one more year of
life I too want to have a long and happy
life but I wouldn't mind if I got to
skip about February to November every
four years we also have a just a just a
note from Maria who asks who's just says
I need to inform you that I've lived in
the suburb with people and with the
half-plane and the Marquis in the yard
for 14 years so we've got there's
listeners all over the place my problem
is that Maria does not tell us what the
Marquis says go down there and tell us
but they do say that I leave a loaf of
banana bread by his front gate every
year and on the holidays I imagine he
probably throws this away but I hope he
enjoys the thought so that's amazing I
love this town
okay Hank I wanted to read one last
email this one is struck me as very
important
came from Pietro who wrote Dear John and
Hank I Pietro all these people trying to
Ryan me I Pietro and the Swiss citizen
living in the United States and I just
wanted to say thank you
well mostly to John you're welcome
Pietro in the last episode you guys but
mostly John mentioned Switzerland and
this brought joy to my heart as almost
no one mentioned Switzerland in any
context ever the last time someone
mentioned Switzerland to me was three
weeks ago as a footnote at the end of a
lesson on the Congress of Vienna in my
history class it sucks that Switzerland
is mentioned so little because it is
such an interesting country like did you
know that we don't have a president but
instead a Council of seven people that
act like the executive branch and we're
the only country with a square flag okay
good can I make a couple of comments on
peut hrus asked so far yeah please do
first of all Switzerland being mentioned
once every three weeks in a place that
is in Switzerland it seems like quite a
lot seems like more than the average
country on earth I'm sure that they are
absolutely try being from Liberia yeah
lots of fascinating things about
Switzerland and and that we should all
know them and that I would love to know
them and I'd love to have read a whole
book about that though probably I would
not love the actual process of reading
it also I will say that Switzerland in
America is is literally a cliche like we
will you will say I'm Switzerland if you
want to say like I'm not involved I want
to be removed from this debate that I
never asked to be a part of in the first
place I'm Switzerland that's it's a
thing that people say it's like it's a
word that means something aside from the
name of the country people mention
Switzerland all the time I feel like
Switzerland gets a lot of play John Hank
do you know the only other country not
to have a rectangular flag uh it's a
triangle isn't it don't Google it no
cheating but it's a triangle right it's
kind of two triangles Oh tell me more
did the flag of Nepal oh yeah it is two
triangles yep crimson red is the color
of the rhododendron the country's
national flower and red is also the sign
of victory in war Oh red the blue border
is the color of peace oh that's nice so
the piece is surrounding the war that's
good news until 1962 the flag
emblems the Sun in the crescent moon had
human faces Wow
that was awesome then they were removed
to modernize the flag which was
incredibly unfortunate basically Pizza
John was a national flag another another
amazing thing about the flag would Nepal
John is a numberphile video about this
in the constitution of Nepal there is a
mathematical equation that is the flag
so like there's a mathematical
representation of how to create the flag
so you can use the Constitution with the
words to create the flag with math
that's very beautiful
somehow fills me with tremendous hope
Nepal has had a fascinating history the
last 20 years I think it's one of the
most interesting countries on earth
right now and I feel like we're really
rubbing this in theatre of space right
now ah okay you wanted to talk about
Switzerland here's Nepal effect
I told you about how interested I am in
Nepal no Switzerland is a lovely country
and everybody wishes they were from
Switzerland obviously they have an
extremely strong currency you know they
don't ever have to fight in wars it
seems like it's a very good life there
but I appreciate Pietro coming to the
United States and I am grateful that
Pietro is here and I hope that you are
happy and that the United States has
welcomed you and I apologize for all of
the terrible things that have been said
about immigrants in the United States in
the last several months and also really
for the last like hundred and fifty
years Oh Hank it's a darkness I cannot I
cannot regal myself out of this darkness
but I will say that I have made another
twenty cents on predicted org while
we've been recording this podcast since
I last updated you I that's terrible
news the more you win the more I worry I
do want to get to this question since
you've brought up immigration I I want
to get to this question from Iman which
I felt like a great question
this was my question of the week I think
this is the best question and I figured
you were gonna want to answer it so I
it's a bond says dear Hank and John I'm
an 18 year old nerdfighter of African
Islamic descent who lives in Norway and
has been doing that for the last seven
years before that I used to live in the
Middle East I came here as a refugee and
have adjust
well to this society since then but I
still struggle with identifying myself
as a member of the society especially
since a lot of people seem to have
problems with accepting me as part of it
Norwegians are very nice and kind people
but whenever the topic of Norwegian Ness
is under discussion I feel immediately
excluded from the majority how do I
accept my reality as the forever
foreigner especially as my chances of
getting back to my so-called homeland
are near zero I think this is a great
question and really important and the
first thing that I would say is that
Iman it is not your fault that people's
definition of nationhood in a lot of
cases is ultimately racist I would argue
like I think that if you define
Norwegian nests as whiteness that's
racist and so it falls to all of us no
matter our national identity to come up
with definitions of that national
identity that do not depend on race you
have to come up with them and to
actually like really incorporate them
into our understanding of the world
which is the harder part yeah absolutely
it is hard but I think I we will link at
the patreon to a wonderful episode of
invisibie Lea that was that was about
this it is not said in Norway but it was
about a young Muslim man who felt like
he was not part of his community in
Europe and the tragedies that unfolded
and almost unfolded because of that and
the eventual wonderful reintegration
into his country that was made possible
by people opening themselves up and
making themselves vulnerable and being
honest about these very difficult topics
so I'm really really sorry that you
don't feel Norwegian and I wish that I
could promise you that someday you will
but unfortunately it's going to be part
of your job I'm afraid to
open people's open people's minds up and
it's it's hard and it's not something
that you chose and I'm sorry that it's
something that you're gonna have to live
with but I do think that you have the
opportunity to make a real difference in
in people's lives and in the lives of
the people who will come after you - the
other thing that I would say is that
just because you aren't necessarily
going to feel like you know you'll never
maybe never feel like a Norwegian person
that doesn't mean that you won't ever
feel home in the place where you live
now
right and that there are lots of
different ways to feel home and and and
and lots of different ways to be a part
of a place and that you aren't you know
that you that you weren't born there can
you know in in that you weren't born
there doesn't you know will always be a
part of your identity that you don't
look like all of the rest of the people
around will always be a part of your
identity but that doesn't mean that you
won't find a way to be at home in the
place where you now live and to be a
part of the place where you not live
yeah I think I think that's a really
important point I also think it's really
important just to have these
conversations and to have these
discussions and ultimately you know Hank
and I are never going to be able to give
as good advice on this topic as people
who are experiencing what you're
experiencing so the other thing that I
would say is you know talk to your
friends both your friends who are
Muslims and who may be refugees but also
talking to your friends who are meet
more traditional definitions of
Norwegian about these conversations we
can make progress on them alright John
do you have news for me from AFC
Wimbledon god I have Hank what if I told
you at the start of this season that the
smallest team in league two that has
just become the smallest team in league
one might next year be the smallest team
in the history of the championship I
would say that that is not a possible
thing that could possibly happen in a
possible universe I also would have
thought that it was impossible
but AFC Wimbledon beat Barry possibly
buri I don't know it spelled bu are wide
nobody knows how to pronounce any of
these League One teams oh it's it's all
pure speculation Port Vale Peterborough
these are all these are all made-up
places in England it's all it's all
right out of Narnia
anyway AFC Wimbledon was taking on
eighth place
Barry over just yesterday actually and
they were down one nil and that looked
like it was going to be the result but
then they scored a tying goal Lyle
Taylor the Messi for Montserrat
the Maserati and Ronaldo scored a tying
goal and then in the dying moments of
stoppage time Hank John Meads
the left back AFC Wimbledon Meads he
scored a header on a corner kick
they won 2-1 the Dons have played 14
games they're sitting on 20 points in
ninth place just one point out of the
playoff spots that just what points one
point out of a playoff spot my goodness
that is something else John is obviously
still a long way to go there's still 32
games left in the season and a lot can
happen and will and it should also be
noted that in addition to being one
point out of a playoff spot there are
only five points clear of the relegation
zone so it's an extremely tight table
but oh man what a great victory for
Wimbledon congratulations to all the
boys and to Neil Ardley our wonderful
manager it's just it's what a time to be
alive I mean if you just if it weren't
for the American election Hank this
would be like one of the best possible
timelines 2016 at least for me in terms
of what's going on with AFC Wimbledon
which is basically how I judge the
quality of the universe
well John as of the recording of this
podcast the Mars news is mixed the
ExoMars orbiter and Lander it's a it's a
two-part mission they they went together
but they split apart has arrived at Mars
and
we are not entirely sure of the result
and I am sorry that I that I I will
update if there is news but it's looking
like at the moment that the lander
entered the atmosphere of Mars
and then after entering and firing its
retrorockets to land it something went
wrong and it did not land correctly and
has not been able to establish contact
way back with oh no the so the this
lander is mostly designed as a way to
test out a new system for landing heavy
payloads on Mars so it wasn't a super
expensive scientific experiment or
anything it was only going to be an
experiment that would run for a week or
two just measuring you know the
measuring wind speed and and like dust
and basically doing some measurements to
have data to make sure that future
missions would be safer so it's bad news
on that front
the orbiter however which is the bulk of
the science experiment of this mission
is fine and it's in orbit and it's uh
it's got another day before it's gonna
start maybe maybe more than a day before
it starts its actual science mission
maybe some weeks but it looks like it
entered orbit just find and it's it's
there and it's doing good so so the
European Space Agency now has has
another orbit around Mars but it looks
like its landing system may still need
to be developed we are not sure yet if
there is any news and I'm able to I'll
record an update and but I've just been
like it's literally just happening right
now so I'm following my - Emily's on
Twitter Emily laughs de Walla who is the
senior editor at the Planetary Society
and Emily calendar Ellie who is also
just a space fan and it's a
correspondent for a new Bill Nye show
and and so I'm getting the news in as it
comes in and so far that the that the
lander survived reentry but we're not
sure whether it landed safely and
surviving reentry on it
is a significant achievement but doesn't
look like probably at this point the
chance is like if I was a bettin man I
would not bet on this thing waking up
okay well I'm gonna go to predict org
right now I don't mean to take advantage
of what is obviously a difficult time
for you but if you don't mind I'm gonna
go to predicted order right now and bet
that that Lander is not going to be
landing safely oh man this is this is
this is my life now Hank I'm a full time
predictor org user I'm sorry about your
somewhat good somewhat bad Mars news why
is this a.org website oh because it's
just an educational project it's not a
commercial project it's it's just for
research purposes only but can you
actually make money oh yeah and do they
make money yeah yeah probably I guess so
so doesn't sound like it's educational
purposes only to me well yeah I mean
Hank would you please stop trying too
harsh on my buzz the only thing that's
brought me a single gray of sunshine
this entire election cycle I just don't
I don't think it's ultimately a healthy
decision John what did we learn today
well gosh what did we learn today we
learned some really upsetting and
terrible things about imitation crab
meat that I desperately wish I could
forget we learned that the single of a
gender nonspecific cow is a catalan and
of course we learned that if Hank could
send one song into space it would be a
song that you just wrote just now about
his song going into space and of course
we learned that you absolutely can get
better at bubble baths in fact you
almost must because otherwise it's not a
hobby that's right all right Oh Hank
it's always a pleasure podcasting with
you but